now what do you do
if you have no sonic no tardis
what do you have left well you always
have words
what can words do everything
hey folks time for a doctor who list
and this one was selected
by my supporters over on patreon when i
have a list that i don't have
like something that i need to do because
of timing for one reason or another
i like to offer it up to them see what
they want so i'm gonna try and give you
my picks for the 10 best doctor
speeches from doctor who part of the
reason this took me so long
to even think about getting around to
was
i had a really hard time trying to
figure out well first off
what qualifies as a speech
like trying to define it because like
when i did say my ranking of
companions i i made for myself a very
rigid definition of companion
i started trying to do that trying to
define what qualifies as a speech in
doctor who but
some of the most memorable things are
just only a few lines long
so you know i just i had to throw it out
i had to give up trying to rigidly
define what qualifies as a speech and i
basically just went with
any dialogue exchange where the doctor
talks for more than
more than a couple sent like two or
three sentences more than that
and it really jumped out of me that was
it
and i didn't even like count the
sentences so some of them might not even
meet that criteria but that it might was
in my head
and there were so many options i
seriously considered doing a top 10 for
every doctor but honestly that felt like
a cop-out
this was hard to come up with this was
hard to rank and i'm probably gonna
second-guess this as soon as it's out
and there are gonna be a million
suggestions in the comments of what i
should have included instead of what i
did
but we're going to move forward anyway
with the
top 10 doctor speeches starting with
number 10 why don't you just
die christopher eccleston series one
dalek there were a number of options
from this episode particularly in
regards to his
conversations with the dalek and
there are other moments that don't quite
land for me like when he has his
conversation you know initially with the
dalek when it's locked up
and the doctor's kind of yo-yoing back
and forth on his on how he feels
it doesn't read quite right here though
this is raw
and you feel all the pain
that he has welled up and tied to these
creatures that he may have been the one
who
ultimately used the moment or didn't we
find out later
spoilers but he
is facing the thing that drove him to
have to do that
and that carries a lot of baggage and
all that baggage comes out
rid the universe of your filth why don't
you just die
so good number nine
look me up this is from series
4 the episode forest of the dead david
10 now david tennant
had more than his fair share of
basically
i'm a badass speeches this for me is the
best though of those of i would say of
that type
in general definitely of that type from
tenant
it really does resonate where he's
where he again you feel the pain
he's he's hit his limit like i'm done
with what is going on now and you don't
know who you're messing with so i'm
giving you a chance to find out
before something goes really badly for
you
i'm the doctor you're the biggest
library in the universe
look me up love it
number eight i carry them with me
this is from the woman who fell to earth
series 11 jodie whittaker's doctor this
is the only entry for jodie whittaker
on this list i wish that she had more
memorable speeches it does seem like a
lot of the time she gets saddled with
just the techno babble
or the historical detail information but
this was a really well captured moment
and this is towards the end of the
episode
where after grace has passed away and
you know the doctor gets asked
have you ever lost anyone of course she
has
she says but i carry them with me so
even though they're gone from the world
they're never gone from me
that's wonderful and sweet
and rings so true for almost any doctor
but especially for this one
that's a really great moment number
seven
something that most people probably
wouldn't classify as a speech
and even if they did most people
wouldn't put on a top ten but i'm going
to
for my personal reasons which i will
explain
i could survive 30 feet from the satan
pit
this is where he is being lowered down
and he's
uh he's talking over the intercom he
hits the end of the cable
and he says you know it could be miles
to go yet
or could be 33 no i have tony
the reason i had to put this on the list
is because this moment
is the reason i got into doctor who i've
told this story before and i'm not going
to go through the whole thing but the
very first moment of doctor who that i
saw that made me go i
need to start watching this was the
latter half of this episode and
that moment specifically i might not
even be a whovian
i definitely would have started being
one when i did if not for that moment
i've
got to get it recognition here
number six one that most people probably
thought was gonna be
a bit higher and that is the scale model
of
war speech from the zygon inversion
peter capaldi series nine
this is a doozy like if you're gonna
talk speeches
this is the big one definitely in terms
of amount of time
dedicated to it it's impressive and the
delivery from capaldi is
absolutely fantastic and he goes through
so much being
lecturing being flippant when it makes
his point better
it's not a game sweetheart and i mean
that most sincerely why are you doing
this you set this up why because it's
not a game kate
the only reason it doesn't go higher is
honestly on a re-watch it goes on
a little longer than it probably needs
to
and towards the very end when he kind of
has his
you know when i close my eyes i still
and i hear more screams than you could
ever count it it doesn't quite ring as
legit as everything up to that point it
doesn't lose me it doesn't lose the
moment but it does
bring it down just a little bit but
man save the entire episode save the
entire two-parter
honestly number five
we all change when you think about it
this is the farewell speech from matt
smith's
11th doctor in the time of the doctor an
episode i don't really care for
but dang it there's a good sign off and
it rings especially true to me as
someone who has
changed a lot over the years
and that's okay that's good you've got
to keep moving so long
as you remember all the people that you
used to be
it's a terrific sign-off moment
and it really does a lot to
sweeten his exit in a story that
otherwise didn't do much for me but
i wouldn't change that regeneration
scene in that closing speed
speech i wouldn't change a word of it
it's perfect
number four i know what this face is for
from the girl who died
again peter capaldi series nine
this is after ishielder
has appeared to pass away and he is
the doctor is looking in this pool of
water
at his face and he suddenly realizes
where he knows the face from and why he
has it
in some ways this speech gets boosted up
because of the weight of history that it
is carrying with it because it was
implied from
his very first episode in deep breath
that there was a reason for this face
and we're getting payoff on an
entire series later so
there is some historical weight to this
it's not just a moment
in this episode it is a moment that
feels like a culmination of a lot that
has come before
and i also love it as a statement of
purpose to remind me
to hold me to the mark
i'm the doctor and i save people
because he's wearing the face of someone
he saved
so that every time he sees his
reflection anywhere
that is what he sees you saved this
person
you save people that is what you do
and that's that's wonderful
i love the sentiment i love the moment i
love it as a combination
of things that have been going on with
capaldi in his
series and a half up to that point
number
three pile of good things
vincent and the doctor this was an
episode i didn't totally get the first
time i watched it
but it is an episode that its meaning
has deepened for me
as years have gone on and every time i
rewatch it it has such
a great understanding of the
complexities
and the difficulties of
caring deeply about someone
with severe depression and
this speech especially and i think it's
one that a lot of people would benefit
from hearing because
it is letting you know that
even if someone you love
loses that battle ultimately
that doesn't make any time that you
spent with them
where you brought some kind of joy
it doesn't make that a waste even if you
cannot
save them even if you cannot prolong the
life that they are leaving
or make it immensely and perfectly
better
we
and that has value in and of itself
number two you better have expected this
one to be on here somewhere
everybody lives bros just this once
everybody lives it's short
but there is so much weight
behind that because the joy that
christopher eccleston in
series one in the doctor dances the joy
that he injects
into that moment into those words
carries the weight
of every day that he
didn't save everyone
and actually it's the moments leading up
to it that truly make it it's
because he goes up to this kid oh come
on
give me a day like this give me this one
he does this basically quiet prayer
before trying to take off the mask to
see if he actually
did it and that moment that pause of
like
i don't know if i succeeded because
there are plenty of times that i haven't
and then to take it off and the joy and
the rapture
on his face as he gets to declare that
everybody lives
it is wonderful and amazing it's one of
my favorite moments in the show
but it doesn't quite take my number one
spot so for my number one
doctor speech i had to give it to
peter capaldi series 10
the doctor falls and above all it's kind
it's just that shouting at the master
and at missy as to why he's
trying to fight even though he does not
expect to win
and he lays it out plainly
i don't do it to
hurt somebody i don't do it to beat
somebody i don't do it because it works
because it hardly ever does
i do it because it's kind in some ways
it feels like
springboarding off of the pile of good
things
you don't do the right thing because
it's going to change the outcome
you don't do the right thing
because you're going to win
you do it because it's the right thing
to do
you do it because it's kind
and i love that i love that sentiment in
general
i love it as a culmination for capaldi's
doctor specifically who
is my favorite doctor
i love it as again kind of a statement
of purpose
for who the doctor is and why
he does what he does if you're going to
try and explain the doctor's actions
ever that's a big test to take on
but encapsulating the concept of i do it
because it's kind
yes that is being
a doctor that is being
a compassionate person trying to help
because you can maybe
for just an instant and even if you
can't
the kind thing is to try
so that's my pick for the top
10 doctor speeches
now this is a video that does not have a
sponsor which means i'm going to shout
out another creator and this time
we're gonna go with a who tuber
fittingly enough
dominic martin aka the who chaser
he is a wonderful presence he's a
terrific coupe he's a great cosplayer
he's been redoing lately his videos that
are guides to
cosplaying as specific doctors which are
wonderful and very informative if you
yourself want to get into cosplay
if you are a whovian or you watch
youtube videos about doctor who and
you're not already subscribed to him
please do it he also plays the doctor in
a number of fan
films known as the purple doctor and
creators like him are a big part of what
inspired me to
come up with my own look
for the doctor if i got to
just be my own doctor
so check him out it's definitely worth
your time
that's it for this one what did you
think of my ranking whatever your
thoughts are
whether you would have changed the order
whether there are things you're
shocked that i left off whether there
are things i put on the list that you
thought had no business being there
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments
let's talk about it i have a patreon
which is what enables me to keep
these lights on right now uh so that is
a huge help but even if you're not able
to assist me in that way liking
subscribing commenting
sharing hitting the bell they all help
me out so i
greatly appreciate all that but you also
don't have to do any of it
it would be kind but i'm not going to
tell you what to do
my words are not quite that powerful and
at the end of the day
you're the council and i'm only running
the meetings
so until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]